Suppose we're creating
a chat application,
where we have a list
of available friends.
Our array might look
something like this.
We want to use Ruby to print out
the name of each friend in the array.
If we only have five friends online,
it's not too bad.
But what if we have 500 friends online,
or 1000 friends?
Wow, that's a lot of repeated code.
Fortunately, there's a better
way to do this, loops.
Loops are a feature built into Ruby that
helps us reduce code duplication and
let's us repeat things.
In this session,
we'll learn about some of the important
loops that Ruby ships with.
And by the end of this session, we'll
see a few ways to take these 500 plus
lines of code and reduce it down
to this beautiful single line.
All right, let's get started.